the number of different orders in which
four songs ABC and D can be played if no
song is repeated that's the question
what's the number of different orders in
which four songs can be played if no
salt is repeated can just pause there ok
now this number is 24 ok now how did I
know it was 24 there's a really easy
pack we can solve and I'm going to
illustrate it to youtube you should join
us now with me now first by just seeing
about a simpler example and then listing
about ok so watch this that's what's for
salt SS portal let's imagine if there
were 33 is a nice simple number ok if
the songs are called a B and C we can
actually write out all of the possible
orders there are six of them don't want
to suggest one if you think a me see
that's the first one give me another one
hey Stevie ok Vijay hey another one BAC
last two and a to do ok sure to come up
bank it's coming last that's right now
there are six I know there have to be
only six because I can think about this
in a more logical way that doesn't
require me to list everything out and
this should remind you of what we did
back in probability you've got to have
three slots in your playlist right you
can't repeat it so you can think about
this in this way this first saw that
you're going to play before anything has
been put down you've got how many
choices for that first song hey it's
eight or B or C so three choices ok once
you've picked one of them suppose you
pick a as your first one ok how many
choices do you have for the second song
there are two letting you can see you at
B or C right there are two choices here
but once you've chosen those last sorry
those first two songs there's only one
left right so there's only the last
remaining one
that's it now what do you do with each
of these numbers we're going to multiply
a bit all right because what you're
creating is like this probability tree
do you remember the probability trees we
did like a couple weeks ago you're going
to have another way of drawing this is 1
2 3 there's your first song a B and C
then after that it branches off again
for the two choices that you have
remaining here would be B and C hear it
a B and C and then lastly and be in fact
you can see these choices up here in my
list right then once you pick the first
two well this one now has to go to see
this one now's to go to be and you what
have I gotta pee on me okay in fact is
this new border earth-like planet before
we flip this one around I'm so question
okay so you can see this is 3 times 2
times 1 you have a look at that monitors
and that tells you what you have to
multiply 1 okay so now we're having to
draw the tree because it would take you
forever for question 1 if there are four
Souls then what's the total number of
ways you can arrange your playlist it's
not 3 times 2 times 1 it's 4 x 3 x 4 x 1
so the ways even four times three times
two times one now for a number like 3 or
4 you could write that out doesn't take
you very long but later one you're gonna
have to do questions right sales like oh
how bad if you have 30 songs your place
and you don't want to stand there riding
30 times 3 million times etc so
mathematicians made up a little piece of
notation that does this oh we called it
the factorial okay so i don't know how
many hues seen on your calculator you've
got it ! learning a new button and the
name of the arm of the symbol of the
operation is mandatory okay you just saw
me just unlock to be power now why is it
! well
excited what's 1 factorial just look at
how we've defined it one factor I was
just one your calculator can confirm
that for you if you like what's a 2
factorial it's just going to be 2 times
1 which is too now you already know it's
3 & 4 factorial are we were 3 factorial
over there oh I torial you can compute
well it's your own fault sorry is not
even on the moment have a look these
numbers are still small enough here to
do it 126 factorial 727 factorial 5040
okay now your calculator can tell you
all these numbers is this is this is 7
times 6 times 5 times 4 times 3 times 2
times 1 now just have a look at these
numbers look at how fast they're growing
really really fast hey I'm opening seven
songs on your playlist that's a really
short playlet but there are five
thousand 40 ways to do it your
calculator I see something I was ok i
have exactly sit down we've only done
stay with me we've only done party right
the main thing about this is actually
your I said this is character to
probability so this is a the number of
ways me funny you reap up everything
yeah very good if the particular order
we want the probability is a CB d right
that is one of the 24 arrangements right
so think back to your probability the
fatal outcomes there's only one way to
play like that and we just decided there
are 24 total different playlists you can
have so that's the probability